ah c'est pas merveilleux justement ben
voilà on a fait basculer son destin
aussi la joie sont déjà dans son hlm le
froid 5 une interview critère de choix
est bien concentré vous là est-ce qu'on
peut être miss france est posé à poil
dans les magazines non c'est clair c'est
très clair même si ça peut suggérer
non non non mais on est d'accord on voit
pas les poils julien si on a un chapeau
devant là pour rien c'est pas encore
d'accord avec la poule maniry tu veux
dire comme ayant la taille ou mes yeux
ça voilà bah oui l'achète
est-ce qu'on peut être miss france et
être arabe
ah oui oui bien sûr c'est leur espère
qu'on aura un jour une miss france
d'origine maghrébine à moussy oui
est ce qu'on peut avec miss france et
avoir un amant nom qui se pointe pas et
qui nous fout la paix oui on n'est pas
obligé d'être vierge non jeu quand même
pas bons airs les toiles d'araignées ou
ça ou ça alors envie de rouler des
pelles de larissa
alors est-ce qu'on peut être miss france
et robert defosse ah bah y'en a qui de
guinée ans après est ce qu'on peut être
miss france est détesté la france ah non
bon il faut aimer la france ben oui
quand même
est-ce qu'on peut être miss france est
végétarienne oui mais enfin c'est demain
ce sont les cris les cuisiniers la
presse qu'ils ont ce qu'il faut ça mais
c'est pour les jeunes gens est-ce qu'on
peut être ni semences et pitau
riediennes ça je réponds pas ce genre de
questions alors vaginale change document
on a des millions de pitau riediennes
qui savent pas j'aime viable à ce soir
quel est le pourcentage des militaires
et 55 ans ce à quoi est-ce qu'on peut
être miss france et pour la guerre dans
le monde
non pour la page a dit que les canons de
la beauté de remplacer les canons de la
guerre elle a déjà dit je veux dire je
dirais jusqu'à ma mort 1
est-ce qu'on pète miss france est
détesté les salons de l'agriculture non
annoncés et labourage et pâturage sont
les deux mamelles de la france
signé un bail aux missions elles se
complètent miss pensez connaître des
mots de plus de trois syllabes j'aime
bien pourquoi
oui oui oui un sac un cerveau la place
d'un sac deux sont d'accord un sexe
est-ce qu'on peut être miss pense avoir
fait un porno auparavant non un nom je
viens d'un petit bandeau même si sa
corne on savait que ce conflit
ah bon ce soir non mais pendant du
terroir avec des vrais produits rageurs
des chevreuils à une roue de bris ou
nombreux bah oui vous allez l'audio à
mary sur marne où on est jeune et et
j'ai dit je voudrais du brie de meaux
ouais c'est bon une belle robe ambrée un
bain une étiquette brie de meaux et tu
sais ce qu'ils avaient sur les tickets
non fabriqués dans la meuse
la meuse dans le bon chemin
nice et sochaux est-ce qu'on peut être
miss france y est travestie non au oui
prend que tant que les coûts y sont pas
du maillot et les uzétiens est-ce qu'on
peut être ni semences après avoir été
mis ceux ci sont bons ça n'existe pas
chez universal systèmes ont peu été
intronisé andouille de vire a été témoin
à des accessoires hospital manar et
sophie thalmann a refusé à l'orangé
prize en intronisant du devis est ce
qu'on fait miss france et portait un
string
bah oui ils en mettent ou non dans le
bouquin bravo vous êtes arrivé à faire
parler geneviève du penty de la gaine la
guêpière encore je voulais dire
avis aux amateurs j'ai retrouvé une
photo geneviève lui dit quand j'étais
mannequin mais c'étaient des photos avec
des gaines voile tout le monde
le banquier 100 m
conversation avec cilic
messieurs